okay i've got some interesting follow-up
on the stefan molyneux situation
uh stefan molyneux is a uh an online
conspiracy theorist type dude he is
also i guess under the guise of being
an empiricist a race realist as they are
sometimes called who
is not going to shield us from sometimes
unfortunate realities about the
differences in
uh iq on the basis of race or whatever
anyway
he's become way more brazen lately in
his white
supremacy white nationalism type of
stuff and he's been disguising it much
less than usual he usually will disguise
it as pure science
but as i told you last month here's one
example of how he has spoken
against white nationalism but he's an
empiricist and poland is all white and
it was really great when he visited take
a look
you know i go to poland what is it 99
white i don't need any security the
streets are incredibly clean
crime is almost non-existent
nobody gets called a racist there's no
talk of white privilege
no identity politics
no endless diversity nagging
you know i spoken against white
nationalism
but i'm an empiricist right
i'm an empiricist i went to the country
i saw how it was like yeah so anyway
there's that
and then he and i got into a little bit
of a twitter thing when
he tweeted in early december my
ancestors were driven out of africa and
struggle
struggled to survive winter and hunger
over thousands of years they became
smarter and wiser through suffering
they made the modern world now the
africans say we are privileged
and thieves no suffering made us no more
guilt and i responded to him
can we now say you are a white
supremacist isn't it time to stop
dancing around it so i tweeted that and
then it got like a bunch of thousands of
likes and he started attacking me
even further on twitter uh he
went on and on tweeting a bunch of
different stuff including
i think we have one example of what he
uh tweeted to me or do we not know we
already showed yes here it is while
you're
ignorant of basic facts these same
environmental pressures cost
east asians to have a higher average iq
than whites
it's now official you post confidently
without a shred of knowledge done in
kruger in the flesh so this is a common
refrain actually for white supremacists
which is they say
we can't really be white supremacists
because asians have even higher iqs
so there so i thought that that was kind
of the end of it
but brit one of our viewers advised me
during my youtube live stream earlier
this week
that stefan has been mentioning me a
bunch of times on his channel and i had
no idea
and he's weaving this narrative that
once he confronted me with some kind of
facts on twitter
i vanished because i was just so
defeated intellectually or something i
guess so here's one example
of what stefan has been saying i did
have uh i guess a bit of a running
analysis to this very very briefly with
david pakman i mentioned this before but
um
you know he was implying that i was some
sort of white supremacist and so
i it wasn't that hard i just found some
jewish lawmaker who
said that the jews were the master race
and blah blah blah and said oh that's
he's a real guy you know i've never said
anything like this so let's
let's get together because he vanished
right jewish in group preference never
seen that before
so let's see if i understand he found a
jewish supremacist
in another country who
has only one shared characteristic with
me which is that i'm also jewish
and that somehow is supposed to prove
that stefan molyneux
is not a white nationalist or a white
supremacist it's sort of a weird thing
for someone who claims to be all about
sound and valid arguments to say he
can't be
a white nationalist or white supremacist
because a guy
i don't know in israel who's jewish
thinks that jews are the master race so
that's very weird to begin with
then brett weinstein from the
intellectual dark web
was also involved in pointing out that
molyneux is basically off the deep end
with this stuff
and then in another segment mullen you
mentions both brett weinstein and me
once again
i'm pretty sure that i don't know about
ben shapiro or dave
reuben but i did have a bit of a tangle
fest
with brett weinstein and what's his name
david pac-man
kind of a funny name but anyway uh
because they
were brett weinstein on twitter was kind
of
calling my argument stupid about race
and iq ethnic differences
human biodiversity and so on and so um
[Music]
i got a little i've had this kind of
don't engage philosophy for quite some
time but post-poland i'm like
the high road kind of leads off a cliff
so what he says
is that since witnessing how great the
white ethno state of poland is and
seeing how good things are there when
it's just white people
he has chosen instead of not engaging in
these debates online
he has chosen to start calling out
people who i guess
don't like his white nationalism uh and
then later in this same live stream he
points out that hey
after all i'm jewish so yeah there's
that
i think it was dave pac-man who's
jewish was something like you know why
don't you just call yourself a white
supremacist or whatever it is and this
white supremacy thing is kind of boring
it's so stupid
you know i mean if you love your own
wife it doesn't mean that you think your
own wife is supremacist to everyone else
you hate everyone everyone else's wife
you hate all women it's just
and of course you know when it comes to
the iq stuff given that whites kind of
float somewhere in the middle the idea
that it's a supremacist measure is kind
of ridiculous
but what i did with dave david pac-man
was
i said and it's not that hard to find
right so i looked up and i found
a jewish lawmaker right in israel
who had basically said that jews were
the master race jews were the best the
jews were superior to all all the other
races
and so i tweeted at him that david
pac-man and i said
wow you know i really hate ethnic
supremacists too so this guy's like he's
pretty influential he's pretty powerful
this guy's a lawmaker in israel
and he's an athletic supremacist let's
get the word out let's try and take him
down
and what do you think happened from
there
radio silence of course radio science
so this he seems to be trying to make
the analogy that
just liking being white is no different
than liking your wife it doesn't mean
that everybody's worse than your wife or
that everybody's worse if they're not
white
but that's not actually what started all
of this he said i went to poland
and even though i've spoken against
white nationalism i'm an empiricist
and things are just much better when
it's all white people
now whatever tweet he says he sent me i
didn't see
but it doesn't matter because what
difference does it make that he found a
jewish supremacist in israel how does
that in any way have a bearing on his
argument
if i say hey look you're white stefan
and there's this white
congressman steve king who's a white
nationalist in the united states
so what what what is that what bearing
does that have on any of
this stuff and then we get to the best
moment of the entire thing
uh stefan starts reading comments from a
viewer
who says something along the lines of
weinstein and pac-man
that sounds like a co-incidence which of
course
cohen being a common jewish last name a
cohen
incidence is what a coincidence that
jews are saying this to you and then
this is just the best molineux says
hey you guys have to really cool it with
the jewish question
not because it's hugely anti-semitic but
because
there's a better approach to dealing
with so-called jewish supremacy which is
just to get better at stuff and start
defeating the jews
pac-man of weinstein must be another
cohen incident
so yeah i mean people always like and
you guys got to cool it on the jewish
question stuff like you really really do
i mean i've certainly talked about it a
number of times but
just do better just just improve and and
do better
and um if you feel some other group is
is superior or or is is
dominating things then just in up your
game
if there's another team that continues
to continually beats your team
i guess you can get mad at the other
team or
or you can just train harder yourself
you know and and so yeah you know
it's it's very passive and it's very um
empty uh to to complain uh so understand
the jewish question is a term sometimes
also called the jewish
problem with hugely anti-semitic
connotations dating back to about the
1880s and
it was dealt with by the nazis the nazis
dealt with the jewish question with
something called
the final solution to the jewish
question
using the term the jewish question as a
legitimate term
is like saying i wouldn't focus so much
on the [ __ ]
problem i would just try to be better
than them right
using the term is uh
pretending that this is a legitimate and
reasonable term to use you're actually
building up the problem by even using
that term so anyway
this is what we're dealing with with
stefan molyneux there he is in his full
glory apparently
i thought this ended on december fifth
but apparently the last month has seen a
whole bunch of other
stuff that i didn't see and uh i'm glad
brit
called to my attention send me your
thoughts follow me on instagram at david
dot pakman will take calls next